We switched to a thing called Thing DB. I think it's still called TDB in the Reddit code.
If you find any code that's called TDB or TDB2, I think,
this one was the second version of the Thing DB that I wrote at some point,
this is what it's referring to, instead of having a table that looked like this--a link table
with a bunch of different columns on it for different things--we would instead do something like this,
we would have a table that just had a couple of properties on it,
a couple of properties that everything had.
Let me see if I can remember these things. Everything has a score, an author, and a date.
There might be a few other fields like ups and downs, kind of encapsulated in the score,
but basically, everything whether it's a link, whether it's a comment,
whether it's a subreddit, anything has these fixed columns.
It's not useful for all of them. It's pretty common enough.
This was called the thing table, and we had a separate table
that every data type had called the data table, and the data table basically had three columns.
It had the thing ID, which thing are we referring to, and it had a key and a value.
For a particular data type--for a link, for example--a link might be represented like this,
we'd have an entry in the thing table, it might have a score of 5 and of course it has an ID 1,
an author of 0, that was my user ID, a date when it was submitted and then it might have a data table.
It may have a bunch of rows in the data table.
It would have 1 row that would be like thing ID 1 equal the URL and another row thing ID 1 title.
So, for every property of a thing that wasn't common across all of the things,
we would have a row in the data table, and these are actually different database tables.
They could be on different machines. This allowed us to add features much quicker.
Because if we wanted to add a new data type to links,
the new links would start getting that new row.
We wouldn't have to go fiddle around with adding it for all the old links. We could just keep our code.
The difference of the link doesn't have this property
pretended it has a default value, and this was really cool.
It also allows us to add all sorts of features without having to get the data types right way in advance.
It also allows us to add all these new data types.
For example, down the road, we'd add subreddits,
so users can make their own kind of categories--their own Reddits--and that's just a thing.
It made our development process a lot simpler, and I wrote this whole layer
that would kind of map our Python objects to these data tables.